[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ah oui moncany d'amour
c'est la galère de calais je sors
[Applaudissements]
les jeunes c'est la dernière de camif au
soir
et jeudi soir on va revenir sur les
meilleurs moments pourrez poser toutes
les questions verglas sur tout ce qui
s'est passé dans l'année un compte les
polémiques tout ce qui s'est passé
on répondra à tous mon camiseta dernière
chronique ce soir c'est là on est sur
une fin de phase de jeu très très
heureux voilà gg on va d'abord je vous
ai préparé quelques petits trucs
quelques surprises je remercierai tout
le monde forcer les durs lourd de vox
notion d'amour pour toi je te le dis va
bien dans ta moi je suis une pleureuse
bébé a faim d'armageddon mon pote ch et
couple aurait sur harry potter arrive et
pas faire un toast en race rare là ils
trouvaient pas poudlard du volume je me
suis régalé bon allez hockeyades émotion
un truc vraiment
déjà j'étais forcément inquiet j'ai
malgré tout on a des rapports différents
les uns les autres mais quoi qu'il
arrive vous allez beaucoup de manques et
je vous aime profondément donc j'ai hâte
et la voyance alors idf1 pendant un
petit peu des nouvelles sur quelques
personnes de l'émission être sûr que la
suite se passe bien parce qu on est
toujours inquiet quand on habite à un
travail rappelez vous ils m'appellent la
nuit bonjour qui s'y fait j'ai bientôt
quitter mon travail donc je vais essayer
d'amener auquel je tiens beaucoup j'aime
les féroces ça va bien se passer pour
eux entre guillemets c'est un travail
qui va continuer sans moi par exemple
canal j y fais tout le temps un petit
peu énervé je voulais savoir qu'il a il
à réussir à trouver 4 matap et d'un
petit peu d'accords ou que tu es moi
j'ai pas de gros problèmes de kanifing
personnellement je pense qu'il se
passeront très facilement de vous
rami autrement il aurait aimé savoir
qu'ils allaient trouver un petit peu le
l'amour dans son cou un petit habilité
parce qu'il il en est à de nombreux
divorces vous avez sa date de naissance
est pas du tout et il commence à coup il
commence à marquer un peu d'huile à une
bonne cinquantaine là où effectivement
il a du bouchon c'est normal qu'ils
aient autant d'iverson janig rémois qui
s'appelle jean-michel il a des gros
problèmes de diction les problèmes
d'addiction nombre d'exécutions d'accord
à dire sans sida carottes et voyez je
suis très bonne voyante j'avais vu juste
quand même la question c'est mon mec qui
fait ni avec un mathieu allait marcher
avec eux s'ils à être heureux tu m'as tu
allais avoir ruf de enfin voilà quelques
jours tout le monde à l'aise bienheureux
quoi il a pour habitude de piquer les
que les copines des copains de quoi
exactement
les quotas n'est que partielle
juste une dernière question plus son
côté sportif je suis comme tout le monde
avec l'équipe de france c'est juste aux
lettres on va être qu'on va la pêche au
coup je pense qu'on va la paix chaud et
sexy manque amis de l'écouter un grand
merci à lille et la fille isabelle que
j'aime faut vous embrasse très très fort
et pas au revoir
allez lol doit bien se passer pour que
nous voyons est bon mais puis alors il
ya plein de gens pour qui c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle que je tue je m'en
aille donc le dax a été annoncée il ya
plein d'animateurs qui sont passé le
message on va arrêter de les vannes est
dans la chronique c'est vrai qu'on avait
un petit peu nos têtes de turc et du
coup la nouvelle a rapidement fait le
tour garde mesdames et messieurs bons
combats le foot ne touche pas à mon
poste non pour ce site utilise une
nouvelle
walo d'iwate et aux coraux camille
combal s'en va camille combal se casse
pas mais ça va devoir vivre ma vie de
deux présentateurs d'animateurs way
geagea c'est moi t'es au courant
ça y est c'est bon camille se casse
ouais en tout cas sachez une chose je
loupe mais alors tous tes émissions les
ou en famille
geagea a beau coup devine quoi combat
elle se casse
enfin pour de vrai mais c'est une
excellente nouvelle
[Musique]
alors oui nelson camille combal
il arrête mais non c'est pas possible
camille combal et les aînés c'est une
[Musique]
dans un instant sur france 3 les a mis à
l'eau tu connais la nouvelle camille
combal samba mais attends c'est la
nouvelle de l'année tu sais quoi je vais
te laisser parce que je vais annoncer la
bonne nouvelle à d'autres by alex alu
j'ai une copine appelé quand même j'ai
un peu ténor mathias et camille combal
tu t'es pmp c'est pas bon ça c'est pas
vrai il s'en va libérer face aux tigres
aux kilos c'est bon je ne suis pas très
bien aussi des clichés qui m'ont par
sophie oui c'est la reine des neiges du
c'est la meilleure camille combal sans
voix ça c'est la meilleure nouvelle qui
puisse exister tombe à cette équipe lots
qu'ils ont fait une drôle de voix lagos
un jeu drôle de voix mais c'est ma voix
je courant que camille combal arrête on
sait pas il va peut-être pas revenir
parce que c'est toi mon technicien sait
très bien génial et william leymergie
merci williams
vous lui fait ranger j'adore merci à
thierry beccaro tous les potes là
franchement ça me lydienne merci à eux
l'un franchement c'est chez nous et on
n'a guère profité à participer aux frais
on a fait ça toute la saison galère l'as
des frères spéciaux des frères spéciaux
ouais y'a un guest aussi qui a participé
aux frères quelqu'un mais voilà qui a
fait plein de choses avec moi depuis
c'est combien de temps 6 ans et embauche
à 6 ans ça passe à regarder il a
participé il a participé au tout dernier
frère en tout cas avec moi de l'histoire
des frères regarde au collet qu'est ce
que vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens
je dirais que c'est un très bon système
en fait et votre frère elle en pense
quoi mon frère me vit pas en france
qu'on n'y a pas vraiment de c'était la
caméra cachée sami est bon on embrasse à
toute la famille les montmirail on pense
fort à vous qu'est ce qu'on pensait des
transports en commun parisiens
je trouve que c'est bien des fois c'est
bien et votre aide en pense quoi
à bouaké frère mon frère il est à
madagascar se passe ici autre entrée en
bourse quoi mais c'est à mon frérot
comment tu vois tu me reconnais
[Musique]
[Rires]
en 2000 je pense que
si vous êtes ont pu avoir le téléphone
de d'or est ouverte toute la nuit
c'est le truc génial je ne suis pas de
paris mais je trouve scandaleux est
votre fringue luxueuse en pense quoi
j'ai pas le faire j'ai pas de soeur
alors moi il en pense que c'est
scandaleux aussi dans ses missions
j'adore ces vision exacte balader sur
quiconque tombe exactement
alors il balade dans paris ne suis même
pas dix tailles balade sur nova la chose
reste des petits poils sorti du rang
c'est beau comme tout homme un peu à la
la ça nous fait plaisir de vous voir la
paix nous aussi en famille
bon bah écoutez les coûts les loulous ça
nous fait plaisir de marcher raconte à
paris on appelle des magnifiques ma
chérie qu'est ce que vous pensez
transports en commun parisiens mais cher
monsieur à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est le
grand bordel ce matin saint lazare le
métro ça va mal on peut voir si le
bordel c'est parce que la france est mon
second pense quoi mais écoutez j'ai pas
de serre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de soeur
but puis depuis noël genod soirée me
conviennent mieux aux sauter la plus
jeune notamment sur la bande am n'a su
servir ces sites avaient 30 ans de plus
c est ce qui se serait passé s'il faut
que je prendrais bien les deux à bayonne
on est bien camille on va y aller je
crois pas écouté on va les amène à les
bâches au gène aura un petit camion
jusqu'à la section encore la patte aux
jouets à verser très fort car valable
c'est tout le personnel hockey voilà tu
sais que je t'aime très rod est toujours
là pour nous aider
voilà merci frérot et tous les gens et
que si c'était mignon là tout ça sympa
ouais ça fait plaisir ils sont très
gentils les gens là tu assumes la banque
inédit soit inédit non pas les coulisses
des frères il a exactement wayne en chef
chez vous étiez au courant et je me suis
beaucoup intéressé à cette chronique on
allait là ne se croise on voulait vous
montrer pour une fois comme on faisait
des faits a plein qui m'arrive mais
alors vraiment ces morceaux il ya un
camion et une caméra quoi s'est aplatie
et à 14 elle est exceptionnelle
les coulisses des frères vraiment ce qui
se passe comment est ce qu'on a
construit cette séquence depuis toutes
ces années
regardez doit tout est révélée mais là
c'est là mon bébé
[Musique]
de francs maçons de merde voilà c'était
le tout dernier frère qui vient d'être
tournée et il ya plein de gens qui
disent mais comment ça fonctionne
comment est-ce que ça se passe comment
vous y prenez j'ai décidé de vous
montrer toutes les coulisses voilà
comment ça se passe les frères on
commence à 13 heures c'est l'heure à
laquelle on arrive avec le camion rempli
de costumes sur le lieu de tournage bat
alla deux grandes manches ça fait trois
ans qu'on se gare sur une voie de bus
donc on a pris pas mal de [ __ ] faudra en
parler kaduna et c'est ici qu'on a
tourné chacun de nos frères c'est la rue
ça paraît c'est la rue montorgueil une
rue qu'on a choisi parce qu'à que des
looks de ouf des looks comme ça comme ça
comme ça bref des logos mais pas dans
mon équipe
arrête des gens pendant ce temps je suis
dans le camion en attente à l'affût du
moindre truc
notre ville est donc enfin on a
quelqu'un cathy rentrer en scène c'est
la styliste qui m'a vit toujours avec un
professionnalisme et un calme qu'on ne
trouve que chez nt pas ça nous on passe
alors ça l'a peut-être la journée ça t'a
mis les bouchées [ __ ] de luge en moi
et ce d'autant en toi de mon ami
d'enfants qui leur pose des questions
huppert pertinente pour les faire
patienter
je suis allé manger à regarder la télé
vous mangez vos crocs de b mais une fois
qu'on a le bon look je me dirige vers la
personne tout doucement sans être vu et
votre n en pense quoi
et ça c'est une époque on a terminé
directement la salle de montage on est
en salle de montage pour monter avec
vous on te rendrai moi ça à fond le
montage toujours un moment de détente
râler mais peuple
c'est incroyable 200 ans pour faire un
truc mais pas comme ça tu mets la plante
au pet mais c'est pas possible
mais un fake comme les houches c'est
sonore ok donc on monte avec les pieds
quoi monteux clavier il peut les pieds
tellement tu montes avec tes pieds tapis
prend une douche quoi ça vaut combien
gel douche aujourd'hui à l'eau assez
pôle emploi apparemment t'as aucun
avenir
il ya une chance pour toi c'est avec ma
cystite sinon je suis en train de pisser
dessus heure actuelle une fois terminée
on doit de la vidéo à la technique il
donne la vidéo à la régie qui balance
tout en direct
et ben voilà c'est comme ça que ça se
passe les frères depuis trois ans on
espère qu'on vous a bien fait marrer en
tout cas maintenant il faut que j'aille
parce que j'ai le cagoulard en double
file
c'est bon j'ai connu les belles et le
gîte dernière chose je voulais vous dire
on a tous besoin de tous les copains des
clips voilà rien d'une surprise pour toi
ah et je voulais je voulais le j'ai
préféré vous chantez jerfel générique de
tpm paix car j'aime bien de faire en
générique chanté mais voilà avec un
petit message et c'est à pour maximum de
monde et pour vous allez beaucoup de
manques et donc je vous le dis en
chansons un amant jean luc m'a fait
rigoler mais c'est vous tous que je
voudrais remercier les photos au visage
ok surtout gilles et ses habits mesurer
gens me croient pas que j'ai oublié les
100 euros que je t'ai prêter isa c'est
le moment ou jamais de terminer ton
anecdotes de janvier être avec vous a
été un privilège comme devoir casta en
rennais
de leur mort est déjà en panique il
pourra plus twitté pendant macro
j'espère que quand je serais parti vous
aurez enfin des scouts de guerre
on avait tous envie pour la dernière
balle en ce nul de quai
06 34 52 84 26 et un grand merci aux
fans jose que sans qui je serai au chaud
nous tous même si je pars j'espère
malgré tout être au maillage de
les pages les plus grandes énigmes à bas
sinon j'appellerai direct le ocs vous
allez tous me manquer même si à la
rentrée vous allez de taille et je vous
donne rendez vous l'année prochaine on
se retrouve tout sur
[Applaudissements]
l'habitat des talus camille famille
désaveu fournir des boudoirs
[Applaudissements]
ça fait six ans ça fait six ans que tu
fais pas trop dit et on a on a voulu
trop mercier ferro pour ta dernière on a
fait un petit combat
camille combal story c'est pour toi
c'est pour vous c'est toute l'histoire
de camille combal en images c'est parti
à la première marie veux pas me dans le
ruck tout commença le 1er avril 2010 sur
france 4
lorsque cyril demanda à thierry brault
quelle était la perle du paf ya une
petite soeur qui s'appelle asap camille
combal
c'est une petite bulle comme ça de
d'intelligence et très très drôle et
franchement cet apparent l'aiment
beaucoup camille combal c'est un ami et
d'ailleurs je suis sûr que nous
regardons en brasse on n'a qu'à celui
qui sera avec nous tous les jours pour
son poste de surveillance camille combal
8 octobre 2012
camille combal arrive sur le plateau de
tpm pays pour la première d'une longue
série de chroniques le pds autre côté
jean banon mais je vis dans le wyoming
jeunes exploitants
dis donc qu'est ce qu'il veut c'est la
bonne humeur plus entraînants oui
[Musique]
chronique après chronique et année après
année une amitié commence alors entre
les deux hommes est nourrie par de
multiples péripéties galéjade en tous
genres qui les transformera rapidement
de simples amis un véritable duo
inséparable
vers un biseau sion n'est comme les skis
mon bijou est ce qui vous fait il m'a
fait
cette irrésistible attirance les
entraîneurs à peu à peu sur le chemin
tortueux de l'amour déjà fait les quais
ma part je les passe mon pote mais pas
les clés de mon coeur va falloir
une idylle impossible à contenir et
étrangers des idées
nos frères syriens
cet amour si fort donna lieu à un
mariage non à de mariage et unie aux
quatre coins du globe
leur amour bien que rouleur resplendit à
travers le paf
[Musique]
est ce que ces rires mon petit couscous
royal tu aimerais qu'on reprenne tous
les deux opté pour un jeu bien embarqué
sur l'autoroute de l'amour
camille fabrique un moult et moult
pastilles plus drôles les unes que les
autres et votre élan bonsoir
ricco causent habits du rire qu'on veux
tu en voilà et à toutes les sauces sur
le tapis en somme une dar k
[Musique]
je te préviens du point que ce soir je
perds h les couilles sur baltagis
inscrire désormais au panthéon des
chroniqueurs camille se décide à passer
le flambeau et équité tpm paix jnane de
2,2 de ma campagne moi je rêvais de
faire de la télé j'ai envie de faire
plein d'autres choses j'aurais pas de
meilleur souvenir qu'ici dans toute ma
carrière je garderai toute ma vie je
voudrais tous sincèrement mais il faut
aussi savoir essayer des nouveaux trucs
et peut-être ce plan d aide s'amuser
mais j'en meurs donc
d'ailleurs si tu n'as
mais peu importe où le vent le maine il
pourra toujours compter sur son gardien
je vous dis la vérité on s'aime
énormément camille m'ont été très potes
pendant six ans ça reste un petit peu
difficile pour nous quand même de ce qui
t il a besoin de conseils je serai
toujours là pour lui pour le mener
toujours plus loin vers l'infini et au
delà
[Musique]
m
c'est toujours moi la caméra manquait
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup donc ali
d'amour alors mon chéri
je vais te dire non mais c'est vrai tu
vas me manquer mon chéri vraiment tu
sais que tu pourras toujours compter sur
moi je suis le seul apte envoyé des
textos à 5 heures du matin même ce matin
d'ailleurs surtout à 2 heures du matin
et 5 heures du matin je met mon or
jamais j'ai envoyé un texto à 2 heures
du matin et un autre à 5 heures du matin
et mon chéri tu sais que je t'aime très
fort je te lis toujours dit voilà c'est
vrai que j'aurais préféré que tu restes
avec nous maintenant je vais on voit là
on sera toujours avec toi
et comme j'ai dit à julien si ça devait
mal se passer ailleurs
tu sais que tu auras toujours ta place
sur ces huit en tout cas tant que j'y
suis et dans le groupe canal
quoi qu'il arrive voilà après je pas je
parle au nom de tous les dirigeants de
canal+
et voilà est en tout cas honteux on sera
toujours avec toi géant radio on se
revoit la cites a besoin de nous on est
là en télé on est là même s'il était
besoin de nous sur un bowling
on se marre je serais vraiment à fait
exceptionnelle pendant six ans que je
vivais à la fois y'a pas eu qu'une
chronique en six ans où j'ai pas rigoler
voilà je te le dis donc t'es un énorme
talent je pense que tu va cartonner
je sais pas si ou tu vas aller mais si
c'est sur tf1
bien entendu au total rats ont rigolé
lecteurs mais c'est vrai que voilà on
sait pas où tu iras on espère que tu
iras sur m6 ou sur france télévisions
voilà moi je dis toujours toute la
vérité rien des femmes ne sont pas deux
amis mais si en tout cas voilà tu as
besoin de nous on sera toujours là pour
toi c'est très gentil et moi je dois
vous remercier tous pour avoir un mot
pour chacun d'entre vous m'avez
accompagné j'ai grandi avec vous j'ai
vécu des moments magnifiques des livres
moins extraordinaire même si c'était dur
vraiment puisque tous les soirs on vient
pour faire rire les gens
c'est un exercice qui est dur qui est
difficile qui est vraiment prenant mes
clichés
toute la journée on vit avec ça il faut
être performant le soir on a la deadline
à rendre et tout ça voilà j'ai beaucoup
fait j'ai fait le maximum
l'an passé déjà je voulais je pensais à
partir et cyril est tous là l'émission
elle été injustement
voilà vraiment injustement juger tout ça
donc j'ai préféré rester aux côtés de
mon ami cyril je n'aurais jamais laissé
là je quitte une émission en pleine
forme qui cartonne quel premier tome de
france qu'un succès magnifique je pars
serein et je suis content et je sais que
vous allez prendre soin de cyril c'est
le plus important chacun de vous
regarder beinheim
sell et vous allez tu sais les bleus
n'en de manquer énormément même pas mon
ami tu es mon frère tu le sais tu que
c'était comme mon frère ah ouais c'est
vrai que voilà on se dit toujours les
choses ou quoi mais voilà ça va être
comme je le disais c'est céder dès les
débuts mais ces deux bleus paient rien
révéler si les bonnes nouvelles pour toi
on espère mon chéri et tu sais qu'on
continuera à s'éclater on continuera
pense à toi et on espère que tu vas tu
vas te régaler et je te le dis juste
avant de partir trois cactées équipe
avec qui tu as travaillé pendant six ans
qui t'ont laissé un petit message vous
seriez parce que voilà elles ont adoré
travailler avec toi
abdul et toutes les équipes qui
travaillent toi regard khamis est sans
aucun doute l'un des actes les plus
sensibles que j'ai connue dans ce métier
c'est une grande grande qualité humaine
donc surtout ne change pas camille c'est
quelqu'un qui respecte tout le monde
les petits comme les puissants à chaque
mot utilisé chaque vanne il fait bien
attention à ne blesser personne mais la
vie comme à la télé j'ai passé deux
années avec le temps il aime qu'il a
confiance en toi c'est la meilleure des
personnes que tu puisse connaître
camif sa était le premier à croire en
moi j'étais stagiaire et le grâce à lui
j'ai pu devenir ce que je souhaitais
faire qu'un droit politique
quand j'ai rencontré toute sa famille
j'ai compris d'où venait cette
bienveillance cette tendresse il ya
intéressés par la vie de tout le monde
ce soit des gens proches de lui ou
n'importe qui tu l'as vu deux fois le
fait que tu te marres à quelque chose ça
lui fait plaisir
très bon en leur temps les clips lapin
chose qui fait en arrivant au bureau le
matin c'est la petite blague comme ça du
matin pour mettre tout le monde et bonne
humeur à tout vent il est saint amour
une gentille qu'il a le souci du détail
c'est un des rares animateurs à être
l'at au bureau et à vraiment être
toujours dans le détail pour fehrer
ailleurs le maximum de personnes
est-ce quelqu'un de souriant
d'enthousiastes c'est le plus simple
c'est pas un mec qui se la pète
j'en suis désolé je voudrais qu'ils
forment tous qui se la joue star qui
nous appellent aloi de 12 à l'eau lionel
j'ai réservé à l'hôtel vingtaine des
toiles à quel moment tu vas te la péter
fait six ans que je connais qui
travaillent avec lui et est toujours le
mot sympa n'y a pas changé en six ans je
me rappelle encore sur les tournages le
gars à chaque fois ils disaient bonjour
il disait au revoir et c'est très rare
dans ce milieu
ça donne le plus talentueux j'ai collé
dans taper un peu toujours envie d'aller
de l'avant de faire du mieux qu'on peut
ils le suivent en fait c'est quelqu'un
qui a su nous faire grandir je me rends
compte qu'il a réussi à faire ça avec
tous les autres membres de l'équipe il
ya toujours une nouvelle envie une
nouvelle idée une nouvelle blague un
nouveau dos et surprenant par sa
gentillesse sa générosité sa simplicité
son élégance c'est vraiment ça qui
marque c'est qu'ils sont closes pas du
tout sur ses acquis c'est impressionnant
il est travailleur il a une volonté de
réussir par lui-même
on arrive toujours à arriver au bout de
la journée en disant qu'on a fait
quelque chose dont on peut être content
fier et parce que lui il a un esprit
très communicatif de bonne humeur de
travail c'est un passionné de par son
boulot camille ça a été juste
merveilleux de partager l'appartement
ses huit pendant des années qui préféra
toujours diffuser l'image d'un homme qui
tombe plutôt que d'un chien qui tombe
toujours voulu porter des t-shirts à des
pièces trop petit et un plaisir on peut
que l'aimer et adoré bosser avec lui un
gars sûr c'est un gars qui va loin je
souhaite le meilleur
j'étais ravi de travailler avec amy
pendant trois ans où qu'ils aillent va
cartonner c'est un coeur on dirait pas
parce que je dois oublier tes amis merci
pour tout tu vas nous manquer de leur
origine c'est un long et beau
disons qu annie tu vas me manquer sans
débat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exc
franchement c
et qui sait toutefois qu'il faut dira
pas ralenti
c'est fait
merci à tous alors ya des équipes qui
sont là que le coton tout l'y faut le
boire
remerciements à toute l'équipe bravo mon
cas mais tu vas nous manquer terreau
mais tu sais que tu auras toujours ta
famille ici assez vite et dans tous
cependant toi c'est que tu aimes et qui
sait que je lâcherais kaboul non merci à
ces huit merci à sgambato encore merci
pour la confiance pour ce propos bon ça
me fait kiffer merci au point d'avoir
été si gentil toutes ces années et merci
aux fans this de cyril de m'avoir
accueilli merci mais et au combat
l'histoire on va nous rendre à distance
et bien sûr merci mille fois que mon
merci à 6
[Applaudissements]
mais commis parce que chaque des
chaumières mais parce qu'on est en train
d'être aussi ce soir et on offre le
trophée d'honneur de touche pas à mon
poste
voilà on suit donc j'espère que tu seras
où le mettre
[Applaudissements]
vous rigolez joie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeune femme intervient en afrique